hi i'm james murphy. have you ever come across
an error when trying to import a module? in
this case it's telling me that i can't import my
function a from a partially initialized module a.
scrolling over it tells me that the most likely
cause is a circular import. in this video we'll
go over how these circular imports commonly
arise and what are the main ways to fix them.
here's the simplest and most common way
that this kind of import cycle can happen
at runtime main tried to import something
from a, so it starts initializing a. it
starts running the code from a, but the first
line in a is to import something from module b,
so it stops initializing a because b has to be
initialized first, and then it hops over to b
and starts running that code instead. but then the
first line in b is that it needs something from
a. so it stops running b and goes over to a and
it would like to just start initializing a. but
it realizes that a is already in the process of
initialization. so that's where the error occurs/
we can actually see this chain of events
unfold in the traceback. here we see in main
it tries to import function a from module a, which
triggered the import of function b from module b,
which then triggered the import of function a
again from module a, which is then where the
final error occurred. the way that things are
written right now we have an import time cycle
between the modules a and b, but if you
actually look at the names that we imported,
we don't actually use them at import time. we use
them when this function a or when this function
b2 are called. since we're not actually calling
these functions at import time, there's no true
cyclic dependency, which means we can get rid of
this import cycle. there are three common ways
to resolve this issue. the first one is to take
your import and put it inside of the function. in
python, imports can happen at any time, including
when a function is called, so if this is the only
place that you need this function b1, then it
could be okay to just do the import right here.
this could actually be even more efficient
because if you never call the function a,
then it may be that you never even have to
import b at all. but let's say that you have
a bunch of different functions in a, and a
lot of different ones use this function b1.
in that case, the better solution would
be to just import the module b directly
and then in the functions where you use it,
use the longer name module b dot function b1.
go ahead and do this conversion for all modules
involved in the cycle. let's see how this resolves
the import cycle at runtime. first our main
function tries to import something from a, causing
a to start running. in a, we get to the import
module b, which triggers b to start running.
in b, when we get to the import module a, because
the a module has already started initializing,
this module object technically exists. since
it exists, it doesn't start running this again,
it just says okay that exists so the b module
will just continue on, finish its import,
and then after that import is done
the a module will finish importing.
the third and final common way to get rid of this
import cycle is to just merge the two modules
together. no imports, no import cycles. however
if you had two or maybe even more modules in the
first place, you probably had them for a reason,
so i'm not just going to recommend that you take
all of your modules and merge them into one,
that would be kind of silly. so for that reason,
you should probably prefer using one of the first
two methods. let's take a look at another example.
the next most common kind of import cycle that
you'll run into is due to using type hints.
this example is not like the previous one
because type annotations are defined on a
function definition or class definition when the
function is defined or when the class is defined,
not when it's run. but if you think about it, the
most common use case of type hinting is not even
at runtime, it's for static type analyzers like
mypy. if all we care about is static analysis,
then we don't even need to do the import at
runtime. the typing module provides this variable,
type checking, which is just false at runtime.
so if you put all the imports that you just need
for the purpose of type checking in one of these
if type checking checks, then none of those will
actually happen at runtime, completely avoiding
the import loop. but now if you import this
function you're going to get a name error because
this name b hasn't been imported. to fix this, go
ahead and add this from future import annotations.
what this actually does is it changes the way that
annotations work. instead of evaluating b as a
name, all annotations are converted to strings.
so now you don't get an error at runtime here
because even though the name b isn't imported,
the string b certainly exists. you should
be aware though that whenever you do one
of these from future imports it's not
necessarily guaranteed behavior forever.
right now this causes your annotations to be
handled as strings, but there's actually a
competing proposal to make them just be evaluated
lazily so they're just not evaluated at all
unless you try to look at them. unless you're
actually inspecting your type hints at runtime,
this probably won't make any difference for
your code base, but you should still be aware.
an alternative solution is to again just use
import modules instead of from module imports.
you will still need the from future import
annotations, and the downside to this approach is
that your type hints look kind of, you know, not
as nice. now let's take a look at a very tricky
cycle that some larger projects will run into.
this is what i call the sub package init cycle.
the actual structure of the package is
important for this example so let's go over it.
first i have a main script, it's outside of the
package and just tries to import some class from
some module in the package and do whatever, very
similar to the previous case. now this package,
my package, contains two sub packages: sub package
a and sub package b. sub package a contains
two modules, module a and c, and sub package
b contains the module b. for whatever reason
let's assume that module a needs something
out of module b. here's module b, which we
also assume depends on module c. but looking at
module c, module c doesn't depend on anything,
so there's no actual cycle here. a depends on b,
and b depends on c. c doesn't depend on anything.
nevertheless when we try to run it we do get an
import cycle, so what happened? the problem here
is not with any of the modules a, b, or c. the
actual issue is in these sub package init files,
our subpackage init files here are re-exporting
some names, in this case classes, from some of
the modules inside of them. doing this is pretty
common in python projects because it allows you to
have shorter import syntax. here i can just have
a client say from my package dot sub package a
import a instead of the longer from my package
sub package a module a import a. the problem with
doing this is that every module in a sub package
depends on the init of the sub package, so if the
init of the sub package depends on all of the
modules in the sub package then you've kind of
made a fake dependency of every module in the sub
package on every other module in the sub package.
that means even though c has no imports at all
c now automatically also depends on a because it
depends on the init. let's see this by starting
in main and following the traceback. main tries
to import something from module b, so to import
something from module b we first have to run the
sub package init. all sub package b does is import
from module b so we start importing module b.
module b wants to import something from
module c, so first we have to initialize
sub package a that contains module c. but sub
package a imports from module a, and module a
imports from module b, so now we have a cycle
because we haven't finished initializing. the
way to get rid of this cycle is to just make all
of your init files blank. if you still want to
give your users a short way to import names rather
than importing directly from the modules you can
define what i call an interface package. this is
a package that has no extra modules just its init.
inside the init you put all the things that you
wanted to import from your other sub package.
now your users can import from the interface
instead of reaching directly into the modules,
and there's still no import cycles. depending
on your use case you might give the interface
a separate name, but a lot of packages just make
the true package that has all the modules in it
underscore whatever and then make the interface
name just the whatever. so what was interface a
just became sub package a and what was sub
package a became underscore sub package a.
finally let's take a look at the worst example.
we're back to just a flat directory structure,
we just have two modules but in this case both of
the modules depend on each other, a depends on b,
b depends on a, and they actually use those
dependencies at import time. this is the worst
and most difficult case, primarily because
this often involves an architectural error.
if you're actually using something from b
in a, then that thing needs to be defined,
so b needs to be initialized before a. but
if you're also using something from a in b,
then a needs to be initialized before b. well
which one is it? does b need to come before a,
or does a need to come before b? in my
experience, if your modules are that
intertwined that they need each other both at
import time, that kind of suggests to me that
they should probably be the same module,
merging them together is your best bet.
however, the most common case that i see
this come up is when someone tries to mix
library code with script code. most commonly these
import time dependencies are not really necessary
and you should just pull them out into a script
and leave the remaining library code alone.
if you can't strip out these import time
dependencies then i'm sorry, there's not
much i can do to help you. your application
needs some serious redesigning, it's going
to be a mess no matter how you do it, and there's
no general advice i can give you. just good luck.
as always, thank you for watching. thank you to
my patrons and donors for supporting me. don't
forget to subscribe, comment, and slap that like
button an odd number of times, see you next time